[Musica]
in cambio di un filtro d'amore sapete
c'è una bella una scala scovil quindi è
fuoco
puro se non mi fai uscire te la faccio
sul letto S hai capito bene schiava se
non mi fai uscire ti facci la Prim sul
letto
Ah è arrivata questa lettera strana è
indirizzata a te ma non so da parte di
chi Che schifo Che cos'è E se Brown eh
Che cos'è questo non capisco posso
dedicarmi finalmente alla ricerca di
biscotti torte tutto quello che c'è
disponibile andiamo venite con me mi
ricordo che erano qui controlliamo
magari troviamo qualcos'altro
Tutti gli attrezzi di fiamma che sono
qui le sue provette c'è ancora qualcosa
di marcio qua dentro No no no no no
lasciamo lasciamo andiamo a vedere da
qualche altra
parte sono sicuro che qua dentro ci
saranno i biscotti Ehi oh ma è
completamente vuoto c'è nessuno c'è
qualcosa qua dentro No non c'è niente Ok
continuiamo la ricerca
Allora Ehi ciao Ho messo in pausa il
video per dirti una cosa importantissima
e ora uscito il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata agli investigatori del mistero
questo qua potete già ordinarlo il link
in descrizione è una nuova storia in cui
io e vitale apriamo un'agenzia di
misteri in cui dovremo risolvere un
nuovo Mistero in una città stregata e
anche Voi dovrete provare a risolverlo
Ci sono vari indizi nel libro In più c'è
anche un alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi segreti
assieme e se lo ordinate subito
Riceverete in regalo il poster
autografato con dietro l'alfabeto
Segreto e se volete una volta che ce
l'avete Mandatemi la foto su Instagram e
Vi saluterò E ora vi lascio al
video puzza di piede qui è vuoto Qui c'è
qualcosa che non so che cos'è ma non è
sicuramente da mangiare e anche qui non
c'è niente se Don il quaderno di fiamma
m una sbirciata magari c'è qualcosa
dentro ingredienti una banana una banana
si parla di cibo allora vado a prendere
subito il
frollatore Ciao Ragazzi sto scrivendo
qua degli appunti per la nostra
nuovissima agenzia investigativa se non
avete visto gli episodi precedenti
andate subito a vederli dopo questo
video e sto pensando che cosa ci
servirebbe per indagare al meglio in
questa agenzia investigativa forse ci
servirebbe anche qualcun altro per
aiutar
perché al momento ci sono io che sono
modestamente abbastanza brava nelle
investigazioni nelle deduzioni poi c'è
Vitale che si caccia sempre nei guai ed
è bravissimo a mangiare però dai ogni
tanto aiuta anche lui è anche bravo
anche lui in alcune deduzioni Sempre se
non sta combinando uno dei suoi disastri
e poi non lo so forse ci servirebbe
qualcuno esperto in mostri o non lo so
uno scienziato qualcuno che crei
qualcosa che ci aiuti a difenderci dalle
creature ma soprattutto
ancora ci manca il nome dell'agenzia non
abbiamo ancora il nome dell'agenzia come
potrebbe chiamarsi La nostra agenzia di
investigazione di miseri e cose del
soprannaturale scrivetecelo nei commenti
consigliateci il nome nei commenti e noi
leggeremo tutti i vostri commenti e
Sceglieremo poi il nome dell'agenzia
Ma sbaglio o c'è un po' troppo silenzio
che cosa starà facendo Vitale Eccoci qua
ho preso la banana e anche il bicchiere
del frullatore cos così possiamo
iniziare a frullare questa nuova ricetta
partiamo proprio dal titolo la ricetta
dell'
ululato ululato è una ricetta esotica
che non ho mai sentito prima forse sarà
dell'isola di hululu Ma sì sicuramente
Onolulu ululato Allora ingredienti una
banana eccola qui polline maturato sotto
alla luna il polline maturato sotto alla
luna lo troverò sicuramente fuori il
fiore più puzzolente del
Prato Ok Quindi il fiore più pente del
Prato e il Poll maturato sotto la luna
li troviamo fuori andiamo subito in
giardino m
[Musica]
no questo saa di sudore di piedi ci
stiamo avvicinando non è proprio il più
puzzolente Ma magari riusciremo a
[Musica]
trovarlo
Uh questo sì che puzza a giudicare
dall'odore St proprio di chiappe sarà
quello giusto
andiamo Eccoli Questi fiori sono
bellissimi e probabilmente avranno il
polline maturato sotto la luna piena di
non so che cosa Quindi adesso prendiamo
il polline T Ehi ehi polline polline
Perché non esci niente non funziona mi
sta dando però una strana
reazione mi vien voglia di star rud
[Musica]
dire uh sono riuscito a prenderlo un
pochettino Eccolo qua guardate e adesso
che abbiamo il polline andiamo scappiamo
subito dentro a preparare la
ricetta Sto provando a insegnare a
Merlino a riportare i giochini Vediamo
se funziona e iniziamo con questa palla
Rossa Merlino vieni
merl
ehm non dovevo lanciarla quella ma
Merlino non gliene frega niente Comunque
Merlino Ehi ho lanciato una pallina non
l'hai vista ma perché non gliene frega
niente Ehi Merlino Hai visto la pallina
finora non sta andando per niente bene
questo training Ho un'idea proviamo a
lanciare il Fris Bim ince Merlino Guarda
c'è un frisby non gliene frega un bel
niente ho un'altra idea lanciamo
Comunque la pallina più lontano
possibile e vediamo se Merlino inizierà
a rincorrerla pronti 3 2 1
via Sì sta
funzionando Ma perché a Merlino non
gliene frega niente dei giochini è
l'unico cane che non rincorre le palline
proviamo in un altro modo avviciniamoci
noi a Merlino
presto
Ehi Merlino guarda quanti giochini che
ho vedi ti va di
rincorrerci Merlino sembra più
interessato a questo coso distrutto che
alle palline proviamo a lanciargli lo
stesso Guarda Merlino
Prendila Sì sta
[Musica]
funzionando non l'ha
presa Ehi ma c'è anche Circe qua Forse
Circe inseguirà le palline è un po'
difficile per lei riportarle ma vediamo
cosa succede Se lanciamo una pallina A
Circe Ehi Circe
avvicin
pronta
Prendila
Bravo Brava Sir Adesso devi solo
riportar Mer Circe sono più interessati
al giardino che alle palline Proviamo
con l'ultimo oggetto che ho il frisbey
ma lo lanceremo da lassù così Volerà in
Altissimo andiamo Siamo in cima alla
montagna possiamo ora lanciare il nostro
frb con un super
lancio
e mi sa che non ho capito bene come si
lancia il frisbey Ok Questa volta devo
perfezionare la tecnica 3 2 1
via Oh no ho lasciato il frisby
sull'albero E ora come faccio a
prenderlo Oh no lo vedete là sopra
Eccoci qua abbiamo finalmente tutti gli
ingredienti il polline il fiore puzzone
la banana L'aceto di riso che c'era
scritto qui non lo non l'avevo letto Per
fortuna che ho riletto la ricetta e un
po' d'acqua cominciamo proprio
dall'acqua quindi La ricetta dice
aggiungere poca poca di acqua perché
perché poi praticamente Questo si andrà
a gonfiare di diventerà gigante e io non
voglio sbagliare il fiore puzzone
dobbiamo stare attenti a questo perché
non indicava bene quanti metterne
mettiamo un paio di petali Uh che puzza
[Musica]
mm confermo fa veramente schifo Ma
quanti Quanti bisognava metterne non mi
ricordo Boh guarda io provo a metterlo
un po' tutto Vediamo che cosa
succede Uh messo tutto così almeno non
sbagliamo L'aceto di riso anche questo
poco uh uh ho fatto un po' un casino qua
banana che ho Gi tagliato prontamente la
mettiamo qui perfetto e adesso
ricontrolliamo la ricetta vediamo che
cosa dice allora ci vuole anche un pelo
di cane ma c'è anche la variante col
pelo di gatto Sai che ti dico io frullo
tutto adesso e poi aggiungo il pelo di
cane per me e quello con il pelo di
gatto lo faccio assaggiare ad Anita
Perfetto andiamo a frullare Tutto ok
Abbiamo messo tutto qui dentro Adesso è
il momento di frullare pronti E
[Musica]
vai perfetto ricetta pronta i due
bicchieri una variante per me con i peli
del cane Uh e una variante per Anita e
qui ci metterò i peli del gatto
Merlino Ciao Merlino Ciao Ascolta vieni
Merlino Merlino Oh Merlino Ciao Merlino
Ciao ciao vediamo Guarda Ecco i peli di
Merlino ne abbiamo addirittura due Ma sì
abbondiamo e c'è anche Circe Ciao Circe
Ciao Uh Quanti peli Ma no Circe me ne
servono solo uno due al massimo Ok ce li
ho ce ne ho tantissimi i peli di Circe
in uno mettiamo i peli di Circe
nell'altro metteremo il pel di Merlino
pronti e vai mescolare per 10 minuti ed
è pronto attenzione pericolosità 8
perfetto e adesso non ci resta che
mescolare mescoliamo il tutto uh per 10
minuti
Ok provo a spostare il ramo magari
riesco a farlo
cadere si sta
muovendo Ho un'idea proviamo con la pala
a far cadere il free vediamo se ci
arrivo
Evviva ce l'ho fatta è caduto hai visto
[Musica]
Merlino Merlino non vuole ridarmi il
frisby lo sta
distruggendo
Grazie Bravo sei pronto sei pronto a
prenderlo 3 2 1
via e ora Merlino portalo qua dai por ma
lo sta
distruggendo no Merlino io sono qua
Merlino non ce la faccio più a girare
vediamo se sta succedendo qualcosa eh se
stia funzionando Cioè ma hanno due
colori differenti questo è del cane e
questo è del gatto Vabbè per fortuna che
la mia è gialla almeno non è così
schifosa come questa vorrò dire che
l'adoro ad Anita questa e io me verò
quella gialla Anita vieni Anita Sì
Vitale Ciao Anita Guarda guarda che cosa
ho preparato bevi bevi eh Tieni bevi Che
cos'è un frullato Sì è un frullato ha
fatto seguito una ricetta di fiamma e
praticamente è una ricetta esotica di on
luu pensa un po' eh questa qui l'ho
fatta una una per te e una per me ha un
colore un po' Strano però che cosa c'hai
messo dentro eh Tu non ti preoccupare
praticamente È super buona cioè della
fragola mirtilli rossi fiori erbe di
giardino Ah ok Vabbè se solo frutta lo
assaggio
[Musica]
Allora oh non è proprio buonissima
eh Allora tieni Non la voglio più m no
no no no bevi bevi non mi interessa
proprio assaggiarla guarda è proprio
buona la tu perché io non ho messo la
parte zuccherosa i frutti rossi Tu
invece coi frutti rossi è buonissima non
mi convince poi questa ricetta che hai
preso da fiamma cioè secondo voi mi devo
fidare devo bere questa sorta di
frullato con questo colore viola quasi
nero ma sì sono i frutti rossi ci sono
tanti mirtilli è per quello che ha preso
quel colore no E allora perché tu non la
stai bevendo come non la sto bevendo
guarda vti lo sapevo fa schifo mm No no
guarda uh è buonissima m m se è davvero
buonissima finiscila tutta Vediamo se
riesci a finir Ok la Bevi pure tu però
eh m m m m m la tua ha un colore ancora
più
schifoso anche un sapore Beh adesso
tocca a te e va bene siccome l'hai
bevuta tutta l'assaggio anche io
[Musica]
Vediamo che schif che cos mi hai
preparato fa veramente schifo Ma hai
fatto assordare l'orecchio ha assordato
l'hai fatto apposta a fare una cosa così
schifosa e no ho seguito la ricetta di
di di fiamma e poi guarda io l'ho bevuto
tutta Ah vabbè io vado fuori a giocare
con Merlino eh Non mi fare assaggiare
più queste ricette strane ok oh no
adesso mi tocca pulire tutto questo
macello e v bene è un gran Peccato tutto
questo Oh no mi sono sporcato devo
pulirmi Qui c'è qualcosa
[Musica]
non mi ricordavo di essere così peloso
Vabbè V dire che dovrò andare
dall'estetista
e adesso questo dove lo metto eh non
so Eh ma che
florito ma questo che cos'è una
[Musica]
pulce Oh no
tutti questi peli devo proprio andare da
un anestetista no la ceretta no ho
troppa paura della ceretta non lo voglio
fare no no no ah meritato riposo è vero
cirge cirg che cosa ti è successo oh no
oh no Eh ma che cosa mi è successo Che
cos'è questo Aiuto Aiuto c'è qualcosa
che mi segue c'è qualcosa che mi segue
Oh c'è qualcosa che
oh oh oh Aspetta Aspetta forse mi è
venuto in mente è stata la peperonata
che ho mangiato ieri che mi ha fatto
esplodere tutti questi pori di peli I i
peli di Ma che cosa sto dicendo è stata
la la pozione che ho bevuto prima il
frullato che ho bevuto prima devo
assolutamente tenerlo nascosto ad Anita
Altrimenti altrimenti Saro guai No non
posso fare questo devo nascondermi devo
nascondermi
subito Che strano Dov'è finito Vitale e
da è un sacco di tempo che non lo vedo
Vitale dove
sei non stai mangiando tutto il cibo che
c'è in casa vero Ho io un modo per
attirare
Vitale un gelato sono sicura che adesso
arriverà Vitale dove sei
[Musica]
vitale Vitale Sì Innanzitutto da dove
sei
perché ti stai coprendo la faccia No no
non è che mi sto coprendo è che c'è
questo sole fastidiosissimo che mi
impedisce proprio di di attenere gli
occhi aperti è meglio è meglio se sto
coperto sole
fastidiosissimo Eh sì c'è molto sole
fastidioso e quindi m stai nascondendo
qualcosa che cosa hai combinato lo
combinato assolutamente niente
assolutamente Fammi vedere Non c'è
bisogno c'è
bisogno Aspetta aspetta Mi è venuta
un'idea Mi è venuta un'idea avevi
parlato di gelato Mi sa vero Ehi quell è
mio Vitale sta nascondendo qualcosa
cioè qualcosa di grosso a giudicare dal
fatto che non si faceva vedere in faccia
è meglio se vado a spiarlo dalla
finestra
andiamo Ce l'ho fatta non mi ha visto
Anita in più pu anche rimediato un
gelato Solo che adesso devo devo proprio
trovare una
soluzione Ok da questa porta finestra
devo riuscire Anzi riesco sicuramente a
spiare Vitale vediamo che cosa sta
nascondendo non devo farmi vedere
però una soluzione ma non so da dove
cominciare è successo tutto qui Ho letto
il diario di di fiamma ho visto la
ricerca Il diario di
fiamma Eccolo qui magari posso trovare
la soluzione qui sicuramente se c'era la
ricetta ci sarà anche la soluzione no
come l'antidoto questa ricetta Io lo
spero proprio allora la ricetta è qui
vediamo ma ma dov'è l'antidoto Qui c'è
la ricetta ma manca
l'antidoto ma che sta
facendo dove lo posso trovare fiamma non
ha scritto niente qua E adesso che cosa
faccio formula
pozione non mi dire che quel frullato
che mi ha fatto bere
stamattina Oh no no sento che quella
quella ricetta quella pozione mi sta per
trasformare in lupo
mandaro Aspetta voglio vedere
[Musica]
meglio
[Applauso]
Anita
ok Oh
Anita che cosa ti è
successo Non lo so Anita ho fatto ho
fatto un macello mi sa lo sapevo È stata
la ricetta di fiamma vero eh sì sì sì la
ricetta di fiamma pensavo fosse una
ricetta di un dolce di un gelato di un
frullato Ma che cosa ti sta succedendo
cosa stanno tutti questi peli eh Penso
che qualcosa non ha funzionato
correttamente mi sto per trasformare in
lupo mannaro no Nuovamente Un lupo
mannaro non possiamo affrontare
Nuovamente Un lupo mannaro non abbiamo
ancora aperto la nostra agenzia
investigativa e già affrontiamo un altro
lupo mannaro e tra l'altro sarei io il
lupo mannaro quindi è ancora peggio Oh
no Fammi vedere questa ricetta ho già
controllato non c'è un antidoto la
ricetta dell' lulula come d l'ululato d
Lulo lulo
Ma tu appena hai letto questa ricetta
del l'ululato non ti è venuto in mente
che poteva essere la ricetta per
trasformarsi in lupo mannaro e credevo
fosse una
ricetta esotica ululato ho letto io non
ululato ululato e ululato mi sono
sbagliato fa pure rima Aspetta un
momento stamattina tu mi hai dato un
frullato non era lo stesso che hai
preparato vero No non era lo stesso era
diverso e lì ho messo degli ingredienti
diversi e quali ingredienti allora nel
mio nel mio Sì ho messo i peli di
Merlino e un canid e e la la ricetta
richiedeva i vedi cioè la ricetta
richiede i due peli di cane quindi ti
sei bevuto il peli di Merlino sì
oh che schif aspetta aspetta aspetta E
tu invece hai bevuto quelli di Circe
perché vedi C'è la variante coi pieli di
gatto cosa i pelli di Circe e quindi in
cosa mi trasformerò io Ah effettivamente
tu non ti sei trasformata forse non ha
funzionato su di te guarda la parte
positiva è vero Io non ho niente di
diverso non ho neanche una coda Quindi
ah Per fortuna su di me non ha
funzionato ma ora dobbiamo subito
trovare un antidoto per te prima che la
trasformazione si completi era quello
che stavo cercando di fare qui con il
libro di fiamma ma il quaderno di fiamma
ma non ho trovato niente cerchiamo
qualcosa che cosa sono questi ad esempio
e Quelle sono cose strane di fiamma c'è
anche una cosa galleggiante qui è un po'
bruttina OK Prova a berla Ma che cosa
stai dicendo mica bevo questa schifezza
così ti sei bevuta i peli di
Merlino Ma questa puzza Beh i peli di
Merlino Non puzzavano un pochettino Sì
ma vabbè
Merlino Beh no Ha funzionato No non
credo che abbia funzionato ci sono
ancora tutti i peli Oh no come facciamo
allora da quello che mi ricordo tutte le
altre volte che abbiamo affrontato i
lupi mannari abbiamo utilizzato
l'argento vi ricordate c'è scritto anche
nel mio libro A proposito Voi ce l'avete
storie paurose e ora ho addosso una
collana d'argento quindi possiamo fare
qualcosa con l'argento proviamo da
aspetta vuoi usare la collana d'argento
su di me poi se poi mi fai del male ma
che sto cercando di Det trasformarti Dai
tocca questa
collana non sta succedendo niente u fa E
allora che cosa facciamo an sento che
stanno Mi sto trasformando ci sono più
peli se mi viene voglia
di grattarmi questo specchio è un po'
Strano magari possiamo provare a
specchiarti e magari provi a dire una
formula allo specchio e può funzionare
Magari provo io a dire una formula allo
specchio l'ho visto in qualche film in
dei film funzionava allora che Quale può
essere la formula Quale può essere fammi
pensare Non lo so sei tu l'esperta
qualcosa ha a che fare con l'upo mannaro
sicuramente aspetta prima Guardati allo
specchio guardo sì sì sì eh lupo mannaro
mi invento una rima Torna come
[Musica]
prima che sta
succedendo
Vitale mi sa che non ha funzionato per
niente
[Musica]
ah
Ah per fortuna sono riuscita a
nascondermi bene il lupo mannaro Vitale
non mi ha trovata ma ora cosa faccio
Devo riuscire a scappare dentro casa
senza farmi vedere la porta per fortuna
è rimasta aperta proviamo ad
entrare andiamo Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di
Anita Sbaglio o ancora non hai cliccato
mi piace Mi raccomando Clicca subito mi
piace sotto questo video e se non hai
ancora il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata agli investigatori del mistero
Clicca nel link in descrizione Per
ordinarlo subito e lo troverai in
libreria dal 17 ottobre Prendilo anche
tu per entrare a far parte del nostro
team di investigatori e risolveremo un
sacco di misteri
[Musica]
[Applauso]
assieme
[Musica]
devo assolutamente trovare una soluzione
il prima
possibile
Ho avuto
un'idea c'è solo modo adesso per uscire
da questa situazione devo chiedere aiuto
al nostro amico il lupo Nex Ve lo
ricordate se non sapete di cosa sto
parlando vi lascio la casellina alla
fine di questo video così vedrete tutta
la storia in cui abbiamo conosciuto il
lupo lex dal mio libro storie paurose
scuola di misteri voi ce l'avete ma ora
non ci resta che chiamarlo e come si
faceva bussare tre volte e girare due
volte non me lo ricordo ma lex aiuto
abbiamo bisogno di
[Musica]
te chi mi ha chiamato
Ciao come stai Tu come stai Anzi dove
sei finito dov'eri finito Ma io stavo
bevendo il mio cocktail nella spiaggia
in una spiaggia che cosa ci faccio qui
dov'è il mio costume Dov'è il mio
costume costume cioè eri in costume da
bagno Sì in spiaggia Stavo per entrare
in acqua fare il mio bagnetto Ma sei un
lupo e che c'entra anche i lupi fanno il
bagnetto Io non sono un lupo sono un un
lupo è un po' umano ok Vabbè comunque ti
ho chiamato per una questione molto
urgente e molto importante che cosa è
successo Perché mi hai chiamato Qual è
l'urgenza praticamente Vitale ha provato
una pozione da un libro di un Alchimista
fiamma tu ancora non l'hai conosciuta ma
forse la conoscerai e da questa pozione
lui si sta trasformando si sta per
trasformare il lupo manaro cioè la
trasformazione non è ancora completa ma
è sta quasi per essere completa Ma come
Ma tutto questo è successo adesso non è
possibile e comunque io fiamma la
conosco secondo te quell'uovo di dragor
rana chi gliel'ha dato Sei stato tu a
darglielo E certo che gliel'ho dato in
cambio di un filtro d'amore sapete c'è
una bella cagn ma questo è un altro
discorso che adesso non è non è non è a
far vostre non è importante quindi che
cosa possiamo fare come siamo messi Qual
è il piano hai un piano
vero No è per questo che ti ho chiamato
non ho nessun piano Vitale ha iniziato a
diventare aggressivo abbiamo bisogno del
tuo aiuto tu sei un lupo anche se sei un
mezzo lupo mezzo lupo mezzo Comunque tu
conosci Lubi meglio di tutti sei
l'esperto mastrologo no E quindi Devi
aiutarci devi farmi capire come posso
fermare questa trasformazione ti serve
vedere la Formula magari partiamo D
formula Fammi leggere la formula Ok
allora dove l'ha messa dove l'ha messa
dove l'ha messa dove l'ha messa Vitale
c'è un quaderno fate Ah eccolo Era
questa la
ricetta la ricetta dell' lunato Sì no ma
come d l'ululato Ma questa questa
ricetta è stata bandita
tanti secoli fa come Bandita Ma sì è una
ricetta proibita non dovrebbe essere qui
da questa parte del mondo quindi fiamma
usa ricette proibite lo sapevo che
nascondeva qualcosa ma ma quindi che
cosa possiamo fare Allora se io qua
avessi i miei strumenti da un astrologo
Forse potrei fare qualcosa in più ma sai
son rimasti dall'altra parte del mondo
nel mondo delle Creature l'altra parte
mondo In che senso Cioè c'è un altro c'è
un'altra c'è un altro mondo sì non te ne
avevo mai parlato pensavo che saremo
arrivati a questo punto molto molto più
avanti ma visto dove siamo visto questa
situazione Sì il mondo è diviso a metà
da una parte c'è quello degli umani
dall'altra c'è quello delle Creature Beh
io posso andare in tutti e due i mondi
perché sei mezzo umano e mezzo lupo
Brava esattamente ma Magari un giorno
riuscirà a trovare un modo per farvelo
vedere anche a voi Beh No in realtà c'è
un problema perché le creature noi le
Stiamo affrontando qua quindi deve
esserci stato qualche problema tra il
mondo delle creature e il nostro mondo
reale perché ogni tanto compaiono le
creature anche qua Adesso capisco
cos'erano quei quei terremoti sulla
spiaggia Deve essere veramente successo
qualcosa un qualcosa che ancora non
riesco a spiegarmi ma chissà magari un
giorno arriveremo a capo di questo
problema Sì infatti questo è un altro
mistero che dovremo risolvere ma Adesso
pensiamo a salvare Vitale Come facciamo
a farlo tornare normale allora da quello
che posso leggere qua ci sono un po' di
ingredienti Sì un po' strani un po'
particolari come per esempio i peli di
cane Sì come avete fatto a prendere i
peli di cane Come avrà fatto Vitale Beh
ha preso i peli di Merlino Oh Merlino il
mio grande amico Merlino Quindi da
quello che posso leggere qui a parte la
banana che Immagino che sia stata questa
a fargli venire voglia di proseguire e
fare questa ricetta Sì io vedo che qua
ci vuole Sì a parte il pollin sotto la
luna piena va bene ma i due peli di cane
quelli non sarà semplice annullarli
perché vedi questi ingredienti insieme
generano una fortissima combinazione
alchemica e non sarà semplice annullarli
Oh no ma ci deve essere una soluzione un
antidoto qualche altro ingrediente che
può funzionare per far tornare Vitale
normale presto però prima che torni qua
sicuro che lo vuoi salvare Guarda che
non sarà indolore Per lui sì sì va bene
posso correre questo rischio Al massimo
ci facciamo quattro risate perché sai
qual è l'ingrediente quale il
peperoncino il peperoncino Sì e non un
peperoncino normale uno che raggiunga i
2 milioni nella scala scovil quindi è
fuoco puro ma ma ma ma come fa
semplicemente il peperoncino a farlo
tornare normale non capisco qual è il
collegamento Alchemico Beh vedi in
realtà non lo so neanche io esattamente
qual è il processo Alchemico e quello
Bisognerebbe chi dalla fiamma Beh è
chiaro è normale no ma io credo che sia
un qualcosa del tipo particella di lupo
mannaro particella di
peperoncino un qualcosa
così Ok l'importante è che tu sei sicuro
di quello che stiamo facendo quindi mi
basta prendere un peperoncino e
darglielo da mangiare no sì ci vuole un
peperoncino potentissimo Eh ce l'abbiamo
Credo di sì perché Io in realtà devi
sapere Io adoro il piccante io non lo
sopporto perché vedi anche io sono un
po' una creatura farebbe malissimo anche
a me Beh è vero Se anche tu sei un lupo
è meglio se ci stai proprio lontano
allora facciamo così io faccio un'esca
per Vitale e Poggio un peperoncino là
fuori sul tavolino noi ci nascondiamo
qua così e osserviamo e aspettiamo che
Vitale caschi nella trappola e vediamo
se funzionerà ok Questo sì che è un
ottimo piano andiamo facciamole allora
tu nasconditi là ok Va bene Ora vado a
prendere il peperoncino e torno
subito Io ti aspetto qui eh ok guarda
che quello arriva e vede me mi mi fa
fette Eh vai veloce no torno subito Vai
veloce
corri Speriamo che non mi trovi Ma è
quello Ah no Ah no quella è una farfalla
Ah no quello cos'era quello è
l'uccellino che carino l'uccellino Ah
un'altra
farfalla
T ho trovato un peperoncino con un
altissimo livello di
scovil Praticamente se assaggi solo un
pezzetto di questo peperoncino
è fuoco puro è
piccantissimo Ma io adoro i peperoncini
è per quello che ce l'ho perché mi piace
il piccante Lo so è un po' strano però
non lo so Mi piace un sacco Ma vabbè
comunque dobbiamo mettere questa
trappola Vitale non vedo l'ora di vedere
la sua reazione quando assaggerà questo
peperoncino super
piccantissimo Andiamo adesso ho lasciato
l'ex da solo e non vorrei che stia
combinando qualcosa quel fifone
andiamo Eccomi lex ho trovato un
peperoncino con un livello di scovil
altissimo sei sicura fammi
vedere
No no no Merlino questo questo questo
per noi è veleno è veleno Merino Infatti
dovete stare molto attenti voi lo tocco
solo io
Ok adesso piazzo la trappola là fuori
magari la metto sopra questo tavolino e
e poi Speriamo che Vitale sia attratto
dal profumo del cibo e arrivi subito Ok
va bene Tu fai la guardia e controlla
che che non arrivi prima prima che io
sia tornata dentro la camera Ok ok ma
nel caso in cui stia tornando che che
posso fare che gesto ti posso fare che
cosa faccio faccio un fischio faccio una
SC che
faccio Aiutami Non lo so esci fuori e
Aiutami a sconfiggerlo in quel caso no
no no no no no no no così no no non mi
piace me ne torno in spiaggia io ma come
se aiutarci No no no io non lo affronto
Vitale mannaro Ma insomma Alex Sei il
solito fifone Non ti preoccupare non
arriverà adesso Vitale vado a piazzare
l'esca Va bene io ti aspetto qui con
Merlino ok
[Musica]
Ok lex ho piazzato l'esca Speriamo che
Vitale Lom non arrivi subito
Ok adesso che cosa facciamo Ci
nascondiamo e aspettiamo giusto Sì io ho
trovato già il mio nascondiglio ed è
dietro al divano Tu dove ti
nascondi qua non credo che mi veda qua
spero eh Merlino Spostati da
lì
Eccolo è
arrivato stanno
usando dai Mangialo mangialo non sembra
molto interessato no se n'è andato Non
l'ha mangiato
No non ha funzionato Oh no lex il tuo
piano non ha funzionato Vitale ha
annusato il peperoncino devi aver capito
che era piccantissimo e non l'ha
mangiato Cosa facciamo adesso
eh dobbiamo fare in Mod
che
quelles sia più
appetitosa ok Come e come non lo so Me
lo devi dire tu che cos'è che gli piace
a Vitale Beh a Vitale in realtà mangia
tutto è un grandissimo mangione Ma
soprattutto è golosissimo gli piacciono
tantissimo i dolci I dolci Perfetto
allora ma dolci di che tipo Tipo una
torta i dolcetti che cosa gli piace Beh
gli piacciono tut tutti i dolci però non
saprei dove nascondere il peperoncino
forse e se usassimo la panna montata per
nasconderlo la panna montata quindi
piatto di panna
montata Montagnetta di panna e ho
un'idea lo sbricioli dentro Sì così non
si accorgerà che c'è il peperoncino
dentro andrà a mangiare la panna la
mangerà e tornerà normale Spero che
funzioni funzionerà vero funzionerà ma
non sarà un bello spettacolo sarà molto
doloroso Ripeto per lui eh vabbè Mi
dispiace ma è l'unica soluzione almeno
tornerà normale non sarà più un pericolo
Ok vado a prendere la panna vado subito
a posizionare la panna tu fai la guardia
Ok ok se arriva qualcuno avvisami la
senza il piatto come dove gliela metti
la panna Ah è vero tieni
questa adesso che Anita non c'è io beh
uno spuntino me lo faccio anche perché
non ho mangiato niente in spiaggia
Allora vediamo non riesco a c'ho le dita
troppo grosse
vediamo eh Yes Questa è la panna che
dobbiamo usare No scusa scusa stavo solo
vedendo se funziona Ecco tieni tieni
tieni mi ricordi tanto Vitale Ma chi Io
sì anche Vitale ruba il cibo ma Guardami
sono molto più
bello sicuramente sei più peloso Vabbè
vado a prendere il peperoncino Ok ho
ripreso il peperoncino piccantissimo
adesso adesso allora mettiamo la panna
eh bel po' ne mettiamo un bel po' Giusto
Allora io tengo questo
ok mettiam tanta S Abbonda Abbonda
mettine di più
tantissima una montagna fai una montagna
fai così montagna
Wow Mi sembra perfetto perfetto Ok E
adesso bricioliamo il
peperoncino Perfetto io ora aggiungiamo
ancora un po' di panna e vado subito a
mettere la trappola ok Questo sì che è
un capolavoro e tu adesso custodisci
questa ma non mangiarla potrebbe
servirci ancora Ok non Tea però Sì
volevo dire sì ok
Vado Speriamo che funzioni
questa e ora aspettiamo
Eccolo sta arrivando ecolo sì eccolo Dai
dai dai mangia la panna No no ma l'ha
lasciata lì non c'è
cascato deve aver sentito l'odore del
peperoncino Sì sicuramente sì E ora cosa
facciamo Non lo so Aspetta ho un'idea è
un po' drastica è un po' pericolosa
anche Ma è l'unica soluzione per salvare
Vitale e salvare anche noi va bene io
rimango qui No Seguimi ma in silenzio ok
ok Spero che non mi
veda
Vitale Wow ce l'hai fatto
Anita Oh Oh che
schifo F con il peperoncino sembra che
si sia trasformato in uno yeete adesso
sembra L'uomo delle nevi è vero io ne Ne
ho visto uno ed è proprio
così No si sta
arrabbiando deve aver sentito il
piccante
adesso Poverino andiamo a vedere se sta
bene Vitale Vitale come
stai bene e tu come stai ah sei tornato
normale ha funzionato il piano di lex
presto torniamo dentro casa ok ciao lex
Che bello vederti D abbraccio come stai
Ah che bello mi ci mancato Ma ti sei
reso conto di quello che è successo no
So soltanto che c'è un buonissimo sapore
di panna
può Chissà se c'è qualche altra ricetta
segreta proibita qua nel diario di
fiamma lex ha detto che fiamma ha usato
una ricetta proibita chissà che
cos'altro nasconde Vabbè l'importante è
che su di me non abbia avuto effetto
quella
[Musica]
pozione Ma
perché
Ah ma quando quando mi daranno da
mangiare datemi da mangiare schiavi ma
Vitale che stai dicendo schiavi eh
schiavi quali schiavi che cosa stai
dicendo tu che cosa stai dicendo Ma io
non ho detto niente per una volta che
non faccio niente ma è sembrato di
sentire No vabbè niente Fatemi uscire
datemi da mangiare Stupidi umani
Ma la smetti di sussurrare queste cose
ma che cosa stai dicendo Non sto
sussurrando proprio un bel niente ma
stai sentendo le voci per caso Beh in
realtà mi è sembrato di sentire No vabbè
niente forse deve essere stato quel
frullato strano che mi hai fatto bere
Fatemi uscire ho detto se non mi fai
uscire te la faccio sul
letto sì hai capito bene schiava se non
mi fai uscire ti faccio la Pip sul
letto avete sentito anche voi
Beh che cos'hai da guardare
Circe Smettila di stare l'impalata e
Apri subito questa porta sei stata tu a
parlare e chi se no Babbo Natale
Ah che puzza Ecco quello scemo di mio
fratello e Ehi tu ammazzo di Pusi aprimi
la porta Visto che sei là fuori dai
Sbrigati io la apro io con le mie
zampe non ci
riesco è come se sentissi i pensieri di
Circe O forse lei sta comunicando con me
in qualche modo strano non le senti
anche tu ma io veramente non sento un
bel niente Ma sei sicura di star bene
Laita No in realtà non credo di stare
molto bene Deve essere stato quel
frullato che hai deciso di fare
prendendo la ricetta di fiamma lo sapevo
non è mai una buona idea quando Vitale
prepara qualcosa ma io volevo preparare
solo qualcosa di buono da mangiare poi
c'era la banana pensavo fosse una
ricetta classica di un frullato non lo
sapevo che fiamma avesse messo dentro
tutti quegli ingredienti per fare poi
una pozione cosa ne potevo sapere io
Ecco lo sapevo lo sapevo credo che mi
sto trasformando anch'io dobbiamo
trovare una soluzione prima che la
trasformazione vada avanti e poi
succederà come è successo con te che
cambierò personalità e magari vorrò arti
Quindi è meglio che trovi una soluzione
subito anzi controlliamo subito in
questo diario di
fiamma St Vitta un momento non riesco a
concentrarmi Allora la ricetta dell'ato
Hai qualche idea tu guarda però cioè nel
senso io non sarei così tanto
preoccupato perché alla fine io l'ho
bevuto tutto il frullato e quindi è
normale che mi sono trasformato tu ne
hai bevuto davvero poco quindi non penso
che questa pozione sia così potente da
farti leggere o sentire i pensieri di di
Circe Beh in realtà il motivo potrebbe
essere Siccome io ho bevuto pochissima
pozione non mi sono trasformata subito
quindi c'è stato un ritardo Oppure
quella pozione non era per trasformarsi
ma è per sentire i pensieri degli
animali e poter comunicare con gli
animali È il mio sogno è il mio sogno da
quando ero bambina Perfetto Hai visto
allora che ho fatto bene a prepararla
quella pozione Così almeno ho realizzato
anche un tuo sogno Poi dimmi che non
sono perfetto c'è un modo per scoprirlo
chiamiamo e vediamo se riesco a sentire
anche i pensieri di Merlino
Merlino
Merlino se n'è andato
eh Circe puoi aiutarmi a chiamare
Merlino No non mi interessa chiamare
quest' accco di pulci Se lo volete
Chiamatelo voi Io sto benissimo senza di
lui allora Merlino e devi capire una
cosa io ho bevuto una pozione voglio
capire se riesco a comunicare con te E
sì Sì grazie per la zampa Ma senti
Allora dimmi
qualcosa Sì puoi parlari Parlami
Ah riesci a capire quello che dico
Merlino No no non riesco a capire
Merlino non riesco a sentire i suoi
pensieri come con Circe quindi non era
una passione per capire gli animali
purtroppo
Uffa Peccato Mi sarebbe piaciuto saper
parlare con gli animali Ma quindi che
cosa se allora mi trasformerò anch'io E
cosa succederà e succederà che magari
Nella peggiore delle ipotesi oltre ad
ascoltare Circe magari ti trasformerai
in gatto che poi non è che è una cosa
così grave i gatti son carini sono
pucciosi sono pucciosi i gatti
[Musica]
No cos stai facendo Che cosa stai
facendo erita c c
c Oh calmati arita Ah scappa scappa
via calmao di calmo tiita calmo Oh che
c'è eh come Che c'è Che ma eravamo là
fuori stavo parlando con Merlino Eh sì
sì Calmati Calmati ho capito tutto Ho
capito ho capito tutto mettiti qui
seduta adesso ci penso io perché
praticamente penso che stavi per
trasformarti in gatto ma Niti di serio
non ti preoccupare No no no no no Adesso
cerco subito una soluzione vedi già ti
piacciono le coccole come i gatti
proprio visto tu stai qui io vado a
cercare una soluzione magari un antidoto
e per bloccare questa trasformazione che
dove vai a cercare questa soluzione eh
Eh guarda già mi è venuto un paio di
idee dove cercarle fuori ho già le idee
molto chiare Anzi su
come vado subito hai ragione hai ragione
Vado
subito Ok ragazzi Mi è venuta un'idea
praticamente la pozione diceva che c'era
bisogno del fiore puzzone vi ricordate E
quindi se ci volevo una cosa molto
puzzolente so bene io dove trovarla
venite Seguitemi
[Musica]
andiamo che cosa stai facendo Anita No
non si graffia il divano non si graffia
Io faccio quello che voglio Ehi Aspetta
guarda ho portato l'antidoto il fiore
puzzone lo
senti funziona sta funzionando vedi Ah
mi hai graffiato
non mi interessa trovare nessuna
soluzione Lasciami in pace voglio
dormire cosa Ma che cosa stai dicendo
tieni il fiore puzzone tieni mi hai
graffiato di nuovo Forse ho io la
soluzione Devo trovare qualcosa di più
puzzolente e credo di averla proprio
qui ma cosa cosa puoi fare con quella
respira
Beh beh pensavo peggio in
realtà pensavi peggio Questa è una sfida
e io accetto questo tipo di
[Musica]
Sfide
[Applauso]
[Musica]
schifo che schifo che schifo che schifo
che schif ha funzionato scoperto che ha
funzionato non sei più un gatto
[Musica]
vaii
sono un po' stanco Sono dovuto scappare
Anita sta peggiorando E sta peggiorando
anche tanto credo che a breve si
trasformerà Ma l'avete capito anche voi
che cosa dovrò fare adesso come
soluzione vero chiamare quel personaggio
che inizia con la L e finisce con l'ex e
per fortuna che ho qui con me il libro
per poter chiamare l'ex Com'è che
bisognava fare per chiamare l'ex Apri il
libro Gira due volte Ok poi Chiudi il
libro e lui
apparirà Vitale Ciao hai fatto un
atterraggio più o meno poco morbido ma
di nuovo mi chiami di nuovo Sì c'è stato
giusto un piccolissimo problema con
Anita avevo bisogno del tuo aiuto Ci
risiamo non riesco mai a farmi un bagno
nella spiaggia ma
perché perché ci devi aiutare qual è il
problema Ecco vedi Anita Si si sta
comportando in maniera strana ticamente
Ti ricordi quella pozione che avevo
fatto l'altra volta vero Certo che me la
ricordo che ti sei trasformato in un
lubo mannaro con la panna Ti ha tirato
uno schiaffo di panna e tu poi ti sei
ritrasformato in Vitale perché c'
esattamente Sì è giusto Ecco adesso il
problema è che Anita credo si stia
trasformando in
gatto in In che in un gatto Sì in un
gatto perché ci avevo messo i piedi di
Circe nella pozione ti ricordi no
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta ragioniamo un secondo R
ragioniamo Certo cosa succed ferm un
attimo Sì tu eri un lupo mannaro Sì e mi
ricordo che nel libro c'erano due
formule Sì e tu avevi preso i peli di
Merlino Esatto esatto e i peli di Circe
giusto giustissimo non è possibile
no che cosa c'è che non va
Alex Anita si sta per trasformare in
gatto
mannaro
no no no no no no dietro di te stai
davanti stai davanti stai davantino
Fammi da scudo Alex che cosa stai
dicendo Ti ho chiamato perché mi devi
aiutare hanno davvero paura di un gatto
quei due che
fifoni Ma che cosa stai dicendo lex Ti
ho chiamato apposta perché mi devi
aiutare con Anita Mi hai pure detto che
si sta trasformando in gatto mannaro No
no io non ti posso aiutare con il gatto
mannaro non ti posso aiutare perché non
mi puoi aiutare sei una creatura grande
e forte Io sono un mostralo io conosco
le creature E ti posso assicurare che se
un lupo mannaro da una scala da 1 a 10 è
almeno 8 ok come pericolo Come ferocia
come come difficoltà Ho capito ho capito
E quindi un gatto mannaro quanto sarà 6
4 e me
65 come 65 che cosa stai dicendo
Lex
è l'unica creatura che ha intelligenza
astuzia ferocia è troppo forte tutto
questo e tu non sei così astuto
intelligente feroce No tu sei buono non
riusciresti a combatterla cercare di
riportarla normale Vitale io non
combatto le creature io le studio ma
adesso lex che cosa facciamo no no no no
non mi chiedere che cosa facciamo che
cosa fai tu non c'è nessun noi come non
mi aiuti no no no no io me ne ritorno in
spiaggia a farmi il mio bagnetto ok e tu
te la vedrai con Anita trasformata da
gatto mannaro Alla fine l'hai fatto tu
il problema e te lo risolvi Ciao ciao
cia C Ciao ciao E adesso che cosa faccio
l'ex se n'è andato dice che ha paura dei
gatti e dei gatti mannari e certo che è
un po' fifone per essere un lupo La cosa
positiva è che forse Anita è tornata
normale quindi io tornerei in casa e
magari per essere sicuro mi chiudo a
chiave in una stanza così non c'è
problema Ok io
vado
non sanno quello che gli
aspetta devo nascondere Devo
nascondere qui sarò al
sicuro m credo che qui se entra mi vede
no anche qui non ci sto Vabbè dai metto
qui mi aspetterò tanto Anita sarà
tornata normale
no c'era qualcosa qui ho sentito un
rumore Eppure lo continuo a sentire
qua
che cosa ci fai lì
Anita sei pronto ad essere mangiato
Vitale ad essere mangiato Ma che cosa
stai dicendo Anita Ti sono spuntate
delle orecchie là sopra in testa
Preparati a diventare uno spezzatino di
Vitale Io non sono non sono buono da
mangiare Guarda sono sono piuttosto sono
piuttosto amaro amaro
e molto molto poco appetitoso al che sta
[Applauso]
succedendo la porta è chiusa la porta è
chiusa stai cercando
Questa sì sto cercando quella non è che
me la Lancer resti per favore basta che
me la Lanci non ti devi per forza
avvicinare davvero Va bene va bene
Lancia Lancia no Vitale devi avvicinarti
tu a prendere la chiave vieni qua non ti
faccio niente vieni qua dai avvicinati
alla chiave basta basta che la lanci No
no avvicinati non ti faccio niente non
mi fido di te dai non ti faccio niente
non ti faccio proprio niente Guarda sono
solo un piccolo gattino
indifeso te lo giuro non ti faccio
niente niente Aspetta aspetta Parliamo
Io so che tu sei brava sei buona no no
no no io guarda la prendo la chiave la
chiave la prendo Però tu mi devi
promettere che non mi farai del male hai
capito Anche perché mi stai guardando
con quegli occhi lì che non mi sembrano
che ci sia tanto del belli Sì sì sì Stai
calma Stai calma Io la prendo Però tu
non mi farai del male Ok vedi l'ho presa
e tu non mi stai facendo del male non mi
farai mica del male Vedi io mi sto
allontanando per andare ad aprire la
porta e tu non mi stai facendo del male
giusto brava
brava ma come mai quando io mi giro tu
ti avvicini sempre No non mi sto
[Musica]
avvicinando ti ha preso stai immobile
questo Anzi no perché sei troppo pesante
da trasportare cammina dove vado Non mi
fare male con questo unghia dove posso
metterlo non devi disturbare i miei
piani da gatto mannaro quindi ho un'idea
Anch'io ho un'idea ti rido la chiave e
tu mi lasci in pace Va bene mi lasci
scappare Non mi interessa della chiave
come non ti
interessa anzi meglio togliertela non si
sa mai che ti mangi anche questo Aspetta
aspetta Ho cambi Ide ho cambia idea
magari mi può servire no troppo tardi
per scappare cammina
Ok
vai
in trappola l'ho chiusa fuori nel
terrazzo di certo non può saltare giù
perché non può saltare come noi gatti
dall'alto si
sfracello in trapola qua ora devo
continuare i miei
piani mi ha chiuso fuori Mi ha chiuso
fuori la mia unica salvezza adesso è
l'ex ma l'ex non mi voleva aiutare Spero
sia ancora qui magari riesce a dirmi lex
lex dove sei lex lex Aiutami lex dove
sei
lex Ciao lex ma di nuovo mi hai chiamato
di nuovo al mi ha chiuso fuori alita Ti
ha chiuso qui sì Mi puoi aprire per
favore Ah ti avevo detto che non le
voglio sentire di questa storia Grazie
Alex sì Batti il C salvato ma io di
questa storia non ne voglio sapere
niente E come potevo fare Mi aveva
chiuso là fuori non vedi Sono disperato
Non la riconosco nemmeno più ah ogni
volta Questa stessa storia mi devi
aiutare per forza io non la riconosco
più Anita questa trasformazione l'ha
cambiata profondamente non riesco più a
vederla in faccia nemmeno mi fa troppo
paura te l'ho detto il gatto mannaro è
una creatura molto molto più forte eh sì
me ne sono accorto però adesso ho
bisogno del tuo aiuto da solo non ci
riesco ma cosa non hai capito del No dai
lex Ti prego ti prego Dai aiutami
aiutami Dai ti posso aare in qualche
modo io anche poi dopo il ricambio il
favore e ad esempio non lo so Magari
magari hai bisogno di qualcosa che che
che non hai e che io posso darti se
ricordo bene l'altra volta ero
interessato a quelle ricette proibite
nel mondo delle Creature magari io te le
posso fare avere Che ne pensi le ricette
del libro di fiamma dici Esatto hai
visto Già ti sto convincendo Dai dammi
una mano Aiutami
m
effettivamente quelle Potrebbero
servirmi Oh bene vedi dai di Quale
ricetta hai bisogno del mio filtro da no
no no no no no no no no il Distruggi i
mostri creature cosa no niente no no no
no no no Tu hai detto filtro d'amore ti
ho sentito Eh no perché hai bisogno di
un filtro d'amore no no no no sei
lavorato di qualcuno No no no ma come
devi fare Lavorare qualcuno io sono un
astrologo importante tutto di un pezzo
non ho il tempo per queste cose Sì sì va
bene va bene dai Intanto Dammi una mano
con come possiamo fare adesso a patto
che tu mi dai il foglio della pozione
del filtro d'amore va bene siamo
d'accordo Ma hai appena detto
che Fregatene fregatene vabbè vabbè
vabbè Non mi interessa non mi interessa
Sì sì lo avrai lo avrai te lo prometto
te lo
prometto Questa è una promessa è una
promessa Ok allora ti aiuterò a
sconfiggere Anita grazie grazie lex
Grazie Sei troppo forte come facciamo
adesso allora il piano più semplice
credo anche il più efficace sarà
attirarla in trappola in trappola guarda
ma è un topolino Non è solo un topolino
magari per lei è solo un topolino ma per
noi è la nostra occasione di catturarla
Ok va bene va bene lex va bene E come
come come dobbiamo fare allora la
tiriamo la chiamiamo e gli diciamo Eh
guarda c'è un topolino noi useremo il
controller per muovere il topolino dove
vogliamo dove vogliamo attirarla dove la
vogliamo attirare qua in questa stanza
eh e penso proprio di sì è un'ottima
idea E così una volta at tirata qui noi
potremmo cercare l'antidoto per farla
tornare normale Giusto esattamente Uh
grande hai visto Siamo una squadra
fantastica e vai Ricordati quella pagina
de libro la pagina Ah sì certo certo
come andiamo Sì sì andiamo Andiamo
pronto Alex Io sono pronto Tu sei pronto
sono prontissimo Allora poggiamo il topo
qui vai tu guida eh guida bene penso io
ok Vado allora
[Musica]
vai ma lex Eh è andato dall'altra parte
il topolino Eh sì devo aver sbagliato
qualcosa il giorno che dovevo prendere
la patente dei topini Eh non ci sono
andato la patente dei topini Ma stai
scherzando guidi un topolino senza avere
la patente non hai passato l'esame non
hai passato l'esame pratico o teorico Eh
no non ho passato quello pratico perché
beh vedi teorico ce l'ho e le cose le so
Vabbè va Guido io che c'ho la patente
tranquillo Bravo bravo guida tu Allora
pronti Abbassa le orecchie ho paura che
ci vedo che ma un critico
grazie guarda hai visto bravo dai dai
[Musica]
dai è entrata in camera Dai dai andiamo
a chiuderla adesso Cor corri andiamo
Andiamo chudi Chi Chiudi chiudi chiudi
l'abbiamo bloccato dentro chi
benissimo
vinto Adesso però dobbiamo cercare
l'antidoto dai sbrighiamoci a cercarlo
andiamo andiamo andiamo
andiamo
Ah mi hanno
fregato adesso che abbiamo rinchiuso
possiamo finalmente mangiare ma ma cosa
mangiare Ah no non mangiamo Adesso
mangiamo dopo Ah ok Scusa volevo dire
troviamo l'antidoto l'antidoto per Sì sì
sì sì l'antidoto per per trasformare
Anita farti ritornare Anita normale
bravissimo Ah ce l'ho fatta Ok quindi
primo passo trovare il diario di fiamma
sì e dovrebbe essere qui in giro
dobbiamo solo cercare un attimino
Stupidi umani si sono dimenticati che
qua c'è il terrazzo e noi G infatti
possiamo saltare dai terrazzi senza
farci niente cadiamo sempre in
[Musica]
piedi Dove sono andati quei
due cerchiamolo ho fame Ecco vedi qui
c'è la ricetta dell'ato Sì è la variante
del gatto è la variante del gatto quella
che la trasforma in mannaro sì Adesso
proviamo Gir vediamo se troviamo l'
antidoto no ma non c'è nessun antidoto
qui Qui no no no fiamma non ha creato
gli antidoti di queste pozioni Oh no E
adesso ma Alex tu che sei una creatura e
Conosci questi mostri e che cosa fa
paura ai gatti non ti viene in mente
niente un qualcosa per poterlo creare
noi magari l'antidoto ti sei anche
dimenticato che sono un mostro Ovo e
quindi la risposta ce l'ho davvero eh
Certo che ce l'ho e qual è la risposta i
gatti hanno paura di due cose Oh Oh e
quali sono queste due cose lex Prova a
pensarci un gatto quando vede l'acqua
che cosa fa eh Il gatto ha paura
dell'acqua bravo e l'altra Qual è hanno
paura dei cani Ma no non hanno paura dii
cani almeno non tutti Ah è vero non
tutti C'è un'altra cosa quella forse non
la sai no dimmela i limoni i limoni e
Perché i gatti hanno paura dei Limoni Sì
non è che hanno proprio paura della
forma tonda di un limone giallo ahok è
che è che è acido e quando lo annusano
gli dà fastidio ma sei grande l'X Certo
sono Allora ascolta non ci resta altro
che andare a cercare fuori un limone e
poi prendere dell'acqua e portarla sopra
dalla Nita giusto Sì è un piano è un
ottimo piano Ok ma dobbiamo recitare una
formula tipo cantare con una gamba
alzata o qualcosa del genere Oppure
basta lasciargliela addosso così no no
no no no no non stiamo parlando di una
formula o di una pozione dobbiamo
semplicemente lanciare l'acqua con i
limoni ad An e speriamo che funzioni
peré Non è detto Non è detto come non è
detto dici tanto lo farai tu quindi sei
pronto S Prontissimo Andi andiamo
andiamo andiamo di là Dai andiamo andamo
andiamo allora Alex dobbiamo cercare i
limoni qui Qui ci sono degli alberi ma
non vedo dei Limoni quindi dobbiamo
provare ad andare da quella parte
Andiamo dai ti
seguo ci sei lex ci sono ci sono non ti
perdere aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
aspetta Dimmi ma abbiamo chiuso bene
Anita sì Eh adesso che ci penso Sì
l'abbiamo Chiusa bene l'abbiamo chiusa a
chiave Ti ricordi Allora siamo
tranquilli dai Non mi fare prendere
questi colpi però le da tutta calma con
tutta calma ma ascolta Visto che tu sei
un mezzo lupo e mezzo cane mezzo umano
non potresti usare il tuo fiuto per
sentire Dove sono i limoni Ottima idea
allora vediamo Per fortuna che ci sono
io lex eh C'hai ragione e poi chiami
sempre a me però vero eh È vero è vero
Dai allora da quale parte dobbiamo
andare
[Musica]
lex asetto sei tu aspetta aspetta Ma
Alex dovresti farti una doccia Ok grazie
lex sento qualcosa che cosa senti verso
quella direzione Ok andiamo lex Ma sei
sicuro che è qui sì e da questa parte ho
sentito odore di frutti vediamo Ma sì
lex questi sono dei frutti eh non sono
limoni vedi che sono delle albicocche Ah
ma il mio naso ha sbagliato Beh sì è
vero che l'albicocca è un po' acida però
non è acida come un limone no è pure
Strano il mio olfatto non sbaglia mai
C'è qualcosa di strano e che cosa può
essere Allora lex Non lo so c'è qualche
altro odore Ma sembra un odore di gatto
Eh certo lex c'è c'è Circe proprio qui
Ah certo ecco perché E allora ho
sbagliato dobbiamo andare da qualche
altra parte ma Circe si è spostata Sì e
io lo sento ancora tantissimo Cioè mi
stai dicendo che senti l'odore di gatto
ancora qui
Sì C'è qualcosa di
strano che cosa
[Musica]
Lex lex
lexo Oh
no lex lex Aiutami No no io io io Vitale
devo devo andare Devo scappare ma come
mi lasci qui No scusa Vitale non ti
posso aiutare Ho troppa paura dei gatti
mannari troverò un modo per aiutarti no
lex Non scappare
lex lex scappa pure lupo ci penso io a
Vitale no che cosa vuoi farmi
Che paura il gatto mannaro Non pensavo
di di vederlo mai il gatto mannaro Ah
cosa posso fare come faccio ad aiutare
vitale i limoni io posso continuare il
nostro piano anche se lui è stato
catturato io posso continuare i limoni
devo trovare i
limoni da questa parte Eccoli i limoni
li ho trovati il mio fiuto non sbaglia
mai Ah vediamo come faccio a
prenderlo
Ah ci sono riuscito ecco un limone
adesso posso continuare col piano
aiuterò sia Vitale che anitta andiamo Ce
la posso fare
Ah ok adesso che ho il limone mi manca
soltanto l'acqua Ehi aspetta C'è
un'altra cosa che devo fare Mi sono
dimenticato che Anita gatto mannaro è di
là con Vitale devo trovare un modo per
farla avvicinare qua Cosa posso usare Ah
certo l'erba gatta quindi il piano è
cambiato con il mio fiuto troverò l'erba
gatta far avvicinare Anita metterò il
limone nell'acqua e poi
su e spero tanto che funzioni Beh non ho
molta altra scelta è meglio che mi
sbrighi sapevo che ti avrei catturato
alla fine il tuo amico lupo è stato
inutile Chi te l'ha detto Non tornerà
più a salvarti Chi te l'ha detto che non
tornerà a salvarmi Beh perché un fifone
Ha paura di me e di tutti i gatti e come
lo chiami un lupo del genere un fifone
do credi di andare da nessuna parte
stavo solo cercando di scappare l'erba
gatta
qui Ok dovrebbe funzionare io devo
andare a prendere l'acqua e mettere i
limoni
vadoo niente questo
odore che c'è Vieni con me dove stiamo
andando a mangiare
Ah piano però non
miare piano però mi fai male con quegli
artigli È laggiù
ahia è
qua
Eccola l'erba
gatta che
buona
Sì ce l' fatta Alex cosa cosa avete
fatto perché mi avete buttato l'acqua
addosso e Ecco guarda Era un po' una
situazione un po' particolare abbiamo
dovuto intervenire per forza così è uno
scherzo no no nessuno scherzo Non c'è
nessuno scherzo non c'è ma guarda che ti
abbiamo salvato Eh a me sembra solo che
mi avete tirato un gavettone d'acqua in
testa per quale motivo eh per salvarti
ti abbiamo salvato sì È una lunga storia
e adesso non ho il tempo io devo tornare
in vacanza Beh Vitale Ricordati di
mandarmi quella cosa che mi hai promesso
va bene Sì sì certo certo la ciotola di
crocchetta Come no C di SC la pagina del
filtro d'amore Sì sì la pagina del
filtro Ricordatelo sì me lo ricordo chi
se lo dimentica più Ciao Anita Io devo
andare ciao ciao lex grazie grazie lex
Ciao grazie ciao divertiti in vacanza
Certo eh Ok ciao alx ciao Mi devi
spiegare bene che cosa è successo Perché
mi avete fatto questo gavettone d'acqua
Eh guarda Dopo ti racconterò Non ti
preoccupare Hai sentito anche tu sì però
veniva da dentro casa Andiamo a vedere
Sì
[Musica]
andiamo Che cosa Che cosa è
stato
c'è
[Musica]
nessuno c'è
qualcuno forse è un uccello notturno
ehm
[Musica]
Io non ho
paura Ciao Anita è arrivata questa
lettera strana è indirizzata a te ma non
so da parte di chi per Anita storis da
fiamma e chi è fiamma Non lo so Che nome
strano Beh vediamo cosa c'è
scritto sembra una lettera molto lunga
Cara Anita Stories questa lettera Ti
sembrerà strana ma non potevo scriverti
in altri modi rischiando che qualcun
altro potesse leggere queste parole mi
chiamo fiamma e sto cercando
disperatamente qualcuno che possa
aiutarmi con un enorme problema non ho
trovato nessuno esperto in materia
tranne te Ti starei chiedendo di che
problema si tratti Ebbene il mio
problema è una creatura una creatura No
ho bisogno del tuo aiuto perché temo di
fare una brutta fine avrai più dettagli
una volta che ci saremo incontrati
dobbiamo assolutamente
aiutarla Segui la mappa e arriverai da
me Fiam mappa qui guarda è anche qua
vicino Sì andiamo subito allora sì tu
Guidami Io guido Ok vai Tutto dritto
Sì sembra proprio questo il posto ma non
c'è nessuno Proviamo a andare di là
guarda
lì sai che cos'è
questa no Che cos'è un'orma gigante a
giudicare dalla grandezza e dalla
Profondità sembra che sia stata lasciata
da una creatura di almeno 100 kg 100 kg
e da quando sei diventata così brava
nelle deduzioni Beh da quando abbiamo
affrontato tutte quelle creature prima è
vero ma adesso sbrighiamoci questa
signora fiamma potrebbe essere in
pericolo È vero andiamo ad aiutarla
laggiù Mi sembra di vedere qualcosa
forse la casa è lì Sì andiamo presto ok
Deve essere quella teniamo gli occhi
aperti però eh Eh sì è meglio sentito
gli occhiali da sole così ci vedi meglio
Eh hai ragione Sì è vero andiamo dai
che c'è ho dimenticato qualcosa da
mangiare l'aria aperta di campagna dai
non pensare al mangiare adess stai
facendo Vire fame
Andiamo Guarda c'è qualcuno lì Eccola
deve essere lei fiamma m Credo di
sì venite Vitale avete deciso di venire
ad aiutarmi venite yuh da questa parte
venite ragazzi venite accomodatevi in
casa
Grazie Ciao ciao Tu devi essere Anita
tuo
Vitale Ehi Vitale
Cito Benvenuti Finalmente avete deciso
di venire ad aiutare Scusate e scusate
scusate ma ma accomodatevi pure
accomodate
mi metto comodo Sì sì Sì mettiti pure
comodo Innanzitutto ragazzi Volevo
ringraziarvi per avere deciso di
aiutarmi
Scusate scusate
scusate come vi ho scritto anche nella
lettera siete le uniche persone che ho
trovato Capaci in questo campo che Appo
sono veramente
Sal Ma che cosa sta succedendo no tutto
bene tutto bene
ehm
per caso non so avete delle domande e
Beh in realtà sì sì sì tantissime
domande lascia fare a me non ti
preoccupare No io ho una una domanda ce
l'avrei Sarà l'aria di campagna però mi
è venuto un certo Laurino non è che per
caso avrebbe dei biscotti Ma non pensare
sempre a mangiare adesso stiamo parlando
di una creatura è grave la situazione e
vabbè ho chiesto solo dei biscotti ho
detto se c'avevamo delle domande Git no
Sì sono sono Hai visto Ci sono i
biscotti
Cà almeno un'oretta più o
meno però però ho del tè ho del tè
buonissimo Se volete ve lo ve lo posso
offire Allora i
[Musica]
bicchieri Ecco
qua Dunque e
Anita il verde e sei il mio colore
preferito è un po' strana questa signora
tu ti fidi di questo suo tè Sì è vero è
un po' strana però c'ha un colore Strano
questo te in effetti eh Bevilo tu Ma sì
dai che cosa vuoi che
succeda prego prego Vitale Grazie unita
il verde
eh e dunque per me qui Ha un odore un
po' strano
effettivamente ma è buonissimo
l'hai bevuto Davvero Sì Ass Angelo è
buonissimo
Grazie delizioso Il mio tè sapete l'ho
fatto con dei fiori che crescono
spontanei nel mio
giardino Meravigli fiori spontanei nel
giardino Sì buonissimo buonissimo ma
torniamo a noi io avrei un po' di
domande a riguardo di questa creatura sì
Innanzitutto cosa ti fa pensare che sia
realmente una creatura potrebbe anche
essere magari un animale
selvatico Eh sì Cioè hai visto qualcosa
Non lo so qualche dettaglio in più e mi
verso un altro po' di te
Scusate Ecco
qui
delizioso ottima domanda dritta dritta
al punto
vedete sono convinta che si tratti di
una
creatura per diversi motivi
e proprio l'altro giorno Mentre
sistemavo il mio giardino ho visto un
impr talmente grande che ci stavano
entrambi i miei piedi e pensate che
avanzava anche altro
spazio abbiamo visto noi
quell capitato di vedere degli enormi
graffi sui miei amatissimi alberi di
ulivo graffi
profondi Ah non era un gatto quindi GTI
lunghi affilati Ah come affilati
Insomma Quale animale selvatico sarebbe
così gigante se non una creatura
famelica che sta cercando probabilmente
di prendere le olive e raccoglierle e
farne l'olio vaccinandi per poi
soffriggerlo e
peperoncino Lo so lo so che è un'idea
folle ho pensato anche a questo Beh in
realtà non credo che una creatura abbia
bisogno di cucinarti per mangiarti Ma
vabbè come Ma se io fossi una creatura
lo farei e come se lo farei il cibo
cotto è molto più buono Vitale Se tu
fossi una creatura basterebbero 20
secondi per catturarti basterebbe
mettere dei biscotti o qualsiasi altro
cibo Tu sentiresti l'odore a 10 km di
distanza e ciu ti catturai subito anzi
forse basterebbero 10 secondi
effettivamente ma torniamo a noi Hai
ragione C'è un'altra cosa che non vi ho
detto io la creatura l'ho
incontrata cosa e ce lo dici solo adesso
ma come vedi la creatura non ce lo dici
subito che forma AV sì che creatura era
allora E sì Beh in realtà non sono
sicura di averla vista molto bene in
pratica stavo innaffiando i fiori nel
mio giardino quando un Bato alle mie
spalle mi ha fatto saltare gli occhiali
facendomi correre velocissima e per
fortuna sono riuscita a chiudermi in
casa così bene almeno sei riuscita a
metterti in salvo e non ti sei fatta
male Sì infatti Beh comunque abbiamo una
una pista adesso mi servono giusto più
dettagli ad esempio eh quanto era alta
la creatura hai visto Insomma Di che
colore era
Eh non lo so qualche altro dettaglio che
potrebbe aiutar Ca un cattivo odore Non
lo so se aveva un odore particolare
magari puzzava di non lo so buccia di
banana Sì insomma Daci più informazioni
possibili ok Eh non l'ho vista bene ma
sono sicura che era molto più alta di me
era da poco calato il sole quando oltre
al forte boato ho sentito il suo respiro
affannato che mi inseguiva metteva i
brividi stai pensando anche tu quello a
cui sto pensando io no non ci credo È
per questo che io e te andiamo così
d'accordo anche tu stavi pensando a una
pizza margherita gigante vero No sto
pensando che è una creatura di quelle
dimensione che si Gira di notte
restringe molto il campo quindi non non
stavi pensando alla fiz No non è il
momento di pensarla fisso Mor
credo di essere vicina alla soluzione
Credo di aver capito che creatura
potrebbe essere ma ho bisogno ancora di
indagare a questo caso e sono sicura che
riusciremo a risolverlo però abbiamo
bisogno di indagare ancora abbiamo
bisogno di raccogliere più indizi
Certamente avete tutta la casa a
disposizione anzi io ho tantissime cose
da fare per cui vi lascio liberi di
perlustrare A dopo ragazzi Ok ciao a
dopo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao
Ma è un po' Strana molto molto strana
direi Vabbè non perdiamo tempo dobbiamo
iniziare le indagini la creatura te ma
non pensare al te adesso non sappiamo
neanche cosa ci ha messo dentro È vero
però è buona è dolce la creatura
potrebbe essere ancora qua nei paraggi
Forse allora lei ha detto che l'ha
incontrata la sera al calar del Sole
fuori quindi ovviamente Dobbiamo
iniziare a indagare fuori sì Tra l'altro
sta anche calando il sole quindi forse è
il caso che iniziamo ad indagare là
fuori Anzi dobbiamo proprio sbrigarci
andiamo Ehi aspetta un
momento questo odore
vogliono fregare me non ci riusciranno
[Musica]
No qui
no lo sapevo pensavano di fregare
me che bel vassoio di
biscotti
finale
spatiale Muoviti dove sei
arrivo ti sto
[Musica]
aspettandoti Certo che questo giardino è
grandissimo Ci metteremo un sacco a
trovare degli indizi Eh sì è proprio
gigante Ma che cos'è che stavamo
cercando nello specifico come cosa
stavamo cercando f ma ci ha detto di
indagare per scoprire di Che creatura si
tratta Eh sì è vero dobbiamo salvarla
Cioè dobbiamo anche Sal noi stessi
adesso perché se non risolviamo questo
caso la creatura verrà a cercare anche
noi oh no cioè la creatura mangerà a noi
Io voglio mangiare Cioè io voglio
mangiare ma non voglio essere mangiato
dalla creatura Appunto allora
sbrighiamoci e cerchiamo degli indizi
presto presto è arrivato il momento di
sbrigarsi Ecco qua il nostro primo
indizio ma che cos'è questo credo sia un
pezzo stracciato di
vestito Wow Sì Ehi ma prima dicevi che
forse avevi intuito qualcosa si trattava
di questo ho intuito qualcosa in quello
che ha detto fiamma perché ha detto che
la creatura è comparsa di notte ed è
alta più di 2 mì Sì è alta più di 2 m
quindi sai che cosa può essere Sì beh
Dunque alta 2 m sarà sicuramente l'alce
nero dell'Abruzzo No ma che Alce Nero
non stiamo parlando di animali stiamo
parlando di creature dobbiamo anche
sbrigarci perché questa creatura deve
aver smangiucchiare
andiamo via via via
via Molto bene molto bene i ragazzi
devono essere dall'altra parte della
casa e io allora potrò preparare tutte
le mie meravigliose
pozioni Ecco l'altro pezzo
Ma dobbiamo cercare gli indizi capito
Dai sbrigati
ora che Anita Vitale non ci sono posso
finalmente continuare con la mia con la
mia scoperta il mio
segreto Eccovi qua
amatissime e dunque con cautela con
cautela mi metto qua atin appoggio qui
il
calderone
Ecco che cos'era Secondo te questo
indumento una maglietta un vestito boh
sembra tipo una cannottiera m di un uomo
o di una
donna Tutto
bene puzza di ascella e di di di cane
bagnato com'è possibile tutte e due
insieme dai cerchiamo gli altri pezzi di
vestiti se ce ne sono
Siamo partiti da là sì forse dobbiamo
continuare verso là Ok proviamo a
controllare di là allora Oh
m
vomito vomito di
ranocchio
Ah sì è
perfetto quanto basta Guarda laggiù Dove
là in fondo lì sull'albero
c'è il resto degli indumenti che abbiamo
trovato prima tutti strappati quindi la
creatura potrebbe essere
l'albero no qua vicino Ah non avevo
capito scusami
Oh credo sia proprio questa Aspetta
aspetta non toccarla prima assicuriamoci
che sia la stessa lo stesso indumento
che abbiamo
trovato confermo è proprio la stessa
puzza di ascella e cane bagnato ah
vediamo che indumento è te l'avevo detto
guarda Si vede proprio che è una
cannottiera è vero era una cannottiera
Ma perché ce n'è solo metà Questa
potrebbe essere o la vittima della
creatura Oppure era della creatura
stessa che Ma lo sai che non ci avevo
pensato potrebbe essersi trasformata e
quindi trasformando si è strappato la la
cannottiera Il che vuol dire che è una
creatura che si trasforma quindi non una
creatura di forma normale che rimane
sempre una creatura ma è una creatura
che si trasforma e questo restringe il
cerchio ancora di più è un
Transformers no che hai detto tu che si
trasforma Guarda che cosa una pala la
creatura è la pala l'ho capito adesso
c'è un problema adesso che problema la
creatura o ha sepolto qualcosa lì o si è
seppellita dentro Sì anche se è un po'
strana la seconda Anche secondo me lo è
che cosa facciamo rischiamo e andiamo di
seppellire Qualsiasi cosa ci sia là
dentro e va benè bene Andiamo a
dissotterrare qualsiasi cosa ci sia là
sotto Ho paura di scoprire che cosa c'è
lì in realtà Ehi ma un'altra Orma due
altre orme no quindi vuol dire che non
veniva di là veniva di qua la creatura
oppure è entrata in casa
dopo non ci avevo pensato ma ora di
sotterriamo quella cosa che sta là sotto
e vediamo se ci dà qualche Altro indizio
va bene andiamo dai e poi il blu il blu
mal di mare quanto basta comunque Nita
Io ti volevo dire che non mi sembra
proprio una grande idea questa Eh perché
e vedi c'è una fossa e poi ci sono anche
i fiori a fianco Vorrà dire che
sicuramente c'hanno seppellito qualcuno
qui Oh no spero di no ma dobbiamo
scoprirlo solo così riusciremo a capire
che creatura è aspetta Se invece poi è
uno zombie è alto 2 m graffio gli alberi
No è vero Gli zombie non graffiano gli
alberi Dobbiamo capire che cosa ha
seppellito qua sotto Ok dai proviamo
Proviamo a vedere che cosa c'è piano
piano eh
ok guarda qual te l'ho detto che c'è
qualcosa c'è uno zombie là dentro eh
lascialo lì dove stava di nuovo no no no
no c'ho paura lascia ci penso
io Che
[Musica]
cos'è sembra sembrano delle scaglie di
di di un animale che schifo uno
scarafaggio forse gigante però tu
Attenta ai
fiori Dai sbrigati e piano però eh Non
so neanche che cos'è ci devo andare con
cautela qui Che schifo Che cos'è E se
Brown eh Che cos'è questo non
capisco sembra un uovo un uovo ma Pasqua
è già passata cosa c'entra e poi perché
è sotto terra e se fosse l'uovo della
creatura creatura che depone le uova Sì
tipo una salamandra o un rettile ma una
salamandra non depone delle uova così
grandi è una salamandra creatura alta
più di 2 m È vero Beh Dobbiamo chiedere
a fiamma delle spiegazioni meglio che
torniamo dentro casa Sono d'accordo con
te
andiamo fiori di primavera
Ah così e
poi poi aggiungerei
della polvere polvere di nuvole così ma
forse un altro
po' Ecco
qua molto molto
bene il profumo è
delizioso questa deve essere la camera
da letto Eh sì Vediamo se troviamo
qualcosa qua dai indaghiamo
indaghiamo Comunque non ti sembra sembra
un po' strano che fiamma si è dileguata
così velocemente dicendo che aveva da
fare m Hai dei sospetti su di
lei forse quasi però visto che siamo in
camera da letto di fiamma Potremmo
cercare qualche indizio Ok magari lì
nasconde qualcosa Sì sono d'accordo con
te Non vi sembra un po' strana anche a
voi magari proprio qua troveremo
qualcosa che ci farà capire
se lei potrebbe essere la creatura vero
pensi che sia lei la creatura non ne
sono sicura ma dobbiamo cercare qualche
indizio se fosse lei la creatura
dovremmo scappare velocissimamente loro
l'oro lique fatto ce n'è poco dovrò
andare di nuovo giù nei sotterranei a
prenderne un altro
po' cerchiamo di trovare
qualcosa ci sono solo vestiti È tutto
così normale
qua
che cosa ci fate qui nella mia camera eh
Io non ho fatto niente Non non sono
stato io beh stavamo indagando come ti
avevamo detto e siamo finiti nella tua
camera
perché nascondi qualcosa Ma figuriamoci
figuriamoci e fatti pure Fatti pure io
io torno alle mie faccende
ehm quali
faccende i biscotti i biscotti penso i
biscot i biscotti non vorrei che si
fossero bruciati No no come bruciati Oh
infatti vado a controllare Non sentite
uno strano odorino Ci vediamo dopo
ragazzi a
dopo hai notato anche tu Sì l'ho notato
anch'io ha detto che i biscotti si sono
bruciati ma non c'è proprio puzza di
biscotti bruciati No non pensare ai
biscotti qua c'era un oggetto sembrava
una sorta di una piuma Forse l'ha presa
ed è andata via e ha detto che deve
svolgere delle faccende con
quell'oggetto si fa ancora più sospetta
fiamme No non mi dire Magari tortura le
sue vittime con quella piuma ma no E poi
usa la piuma per spalmare la grassa sui
biscotti No Come no E allora che cosa ci
fa con quella piuma Mi è venuta un'idea
Non ci posso credere Ho avuto un'idea
geniale Pedini Amola andiamo a vedere
che cosa sta facendo sai che questa
volta hai avuto proprio un'ottima idea
Ci stavo pensando anch'io seguiamo la
SPI Amola e vediamo cosa sta combinando
veramente Andiamo ragazzi
andiamo un capello è sempre necessario
Ecco qui è quasi
pronto
aggiungerei spremuta di melanzane quaa
sì è proprio qui che sta facendo Eh non
lo so La porta è CH cosa avvicinati di
più non si sente niente Anita avvicinati
Ok
sbirciamo eccessivo direi
eccessivo Non lo so si sentono rumori
strani
Eh dai fammi
controllare piano piano mica se ne
accorgerà piano
Ecco qua Ma sì aggiungiamo un altro
pochino stai facendo e non si vede bene
l'ultima goccia dell'
liquame piano però non mi
spingere non mi spingere ho
detto Cosa ci fate
qui No cosa ho fatto
attenzione Oh no sta per esplodere
Ecco qua Ma sì aggiungiamo un altro
pochino stai facendo e non si vede bene
l'ultima goccia dell' quam piano però
non mi
spingere non mi spingere ho
detto Cosa ci fate
qui No cosa ho fatto
attenzione Oh no sta per
[Musica]
esplodere
Ma cosa è
[Musica]
successo
stai bene Sì sì
Aiutatemi grazie Come stai Io bene bene
e voi Voi come state sempr un po'
diverso tutto Tutto a terra le mie
pozioni la mia scoperta
Ah pozioni scoperta Ma di che cosa stai
parlando vedete io Eh io sono un
Alchimista un Alchimista Eh sì
modestamente anche molto brava molto
bravo sì Che cos'è un Alchimista
Alchimista viene chiamato chi studia
l'alchimia Ah sì Allora spieghiamo
adesso che cosa sarebbe è una pratica
che coinvolge la scienza la chimica e la
fisica degli ingredienti creando così
formule e pozioni ma di
che sì anche se questa volta purtroppo
non ha funzionato tanto eh però vedete
ci sto quasi arrivando alla mia scoperta
Eh sì che Che tipo di scoperta che di
che cosa stai parlando
Eh è un segreto veramente penso che ve
lo dirò più avanti e ma insomma ma voi
che cosa stavate facendo noi che stavamo
facendo niente stavamo facendo niente Ti
dico la verità volevamo capire che cosa
stavi facendo tu sembravi un po'
sospetta Come ho detto prima Vitale e
Anita non posso dirvelo è un segreto
ancora E sì Ma voi avete scoperto
qualcosa Beh in realtà abbiamo trovato
qualche indizio ma ci servirebbe un po'
più di tempo dobbiamo indagare ancora un
po' non abbiamo ancora capito bene di
che creatura si tratta e soprattutto non
l'abbiamo trovata ancora sta calando il
sole eh vi inviterei a restare qua
questa notte Anche perché se la creatura
dovesse ritornare potrebbe succedere
proprio stanotte questa notte sì sì sì
Però io mi sento molto stanca adesso e
penso che andrò a dormire ma voi
Sentitevi liberi di come se fosi a casa
vostra e per lustrare mangiare dormire
fate quello che volete io veramente vado
a dormire Sono troppo stanca ormai
quindi vorrà dire che rimarremo qui
questa notte sì È l'unico modo per
risolvere questo caso e in più lei mi
sembrava piuttosto sicura che la
creatura si presenterà questa notte sì
non so come fa a esserne così sicura
ancora non mi fido del tutto di fiamma
Anche se lei ha detto che è perché è un
Alchimista ma non lo so c'è qualcosa che
non mi convince No no infatti è molto
strana Non so se fidarmi oppure no Vabbè
prepariamoci per stanotte è meglio se
facciamo qualche ricerca sulle creature
magari troviamo anche qualcosa per
difenderci sì sì sì sì
[Musica]
sì che
sonno Tu che stai
facendo Sto cercando informazioni sulla
creatura ovviamente Ah non sei
spaventato neanche un pochino Beh sono
spaventato per un motivo non abbiamo
neanche mangiato oggi neanche un
biscotto seme a
mangiare c'è la minaccia di una creatura
e tu pensi a mangiare e bisogna essere
in forza per affrontare una creatura
bisogna anche mangiare no Il problema è
che non sappiamo ancora di Che creatura
si tratta Anche se mi sono sono fatta
un'idea ma non sono sicura ancora devo
ancora continuare le mie ricerche Ma hai
mai pensato che magari tutto questo è
una trappola architettata appunto da
fiamma Certo che ci ho pensato e ho
pensato ad altre 15 cose solo che ancora
c'è qualcosa che non mi
quadra Non so è come se mancasse un
tassello per farmi dire sì sicuramente
fiamma La creatura oppure no sicuramente
non è fiamma alla creatura quindi non
possiamo ancora accusare nessuno È vero
hai
ragione cos'era quel
rumore Forse è quello che
temevamo la creatura A meno che era non
fiamma che si sta facendo uno scherzo ma
mi sembrava una creatura molto grande Sì
a giudicare dal dal rumore che ha fatto
ok È arrivato il momento di entrare in
[Musica]
azione
c'è nessuno da dove proveniva il rumore
destra sinistra davanti dietro Secondo
me veniva da lì a destra Eh credo
proprio di sì vabbè Mi fido di te
andiamo a controllare andiamo Mi
raccomando stai attento St piano Sì
stiamo
attenti
cosa c'è là
sotto si sentono solo dei cani per ora E
che è positivo o
negativo per ora positivo se sono solo
cani
Ok Cosa dovrebbero essere oltre cani
Volpi Ti ricordo che stiamo cercando la
creatura non degli animali selvatici Ok
ok
Che strano Abbiamo sentito un rumore
Fortissimo poi usciamo fuori di casa ed
è completo silenzio Infatti sembra non
sia nemmeno successo ma non è che ce lo
siamo immaginato non credo a meno che
non sia fiamma con la sua trappola
Magari è la teoria della Trappola di
fiamma e lei ci ha fatto credere che c'è
una creatura fuori per chiuderci fuori
di casa farci dormire al freddo ma come
già non abbiamo mangiato in più dormiamo
pure al freddo Ma ti sembra normale so È
tutto molto strano Non c'è nessuna
creatura qua mi sembra SH ho sentito un
rumore da dove di là Oh no dobbiamo
continuare a proseguire in questo
terreno così buio e
desolato Eh va bene dai Continuiamo la
ricerca
Ok mi è appena venuta in mente un'idea
che idea se è una trappola di fiamma Sì
vuol dire che fiamma sta facendo
qualcosa che non vuole che noi Vediamo
Ah cioè che lei ci ha mandato qua fuori
perché lei doveva fare qualcosa dentro
Così noi possiamo stare qui e non vedere
che cosa sta facendo lei sì magari una
delle sue pozioni le sta preparando
apposta per avvelenarci mentre dormiamo
non lo so qualcosa mentre dormiamo
Oppure non lo so Forse è meglio se
ritorniamo in casa allora e magari
controlliamo se fiamma sta veramente
dormendo Ok buona idea però non
facciamoci scoprire Questa volta no no
perché ci dobbiamo far scoprire perché
l'altra volta sei caduto
eh l'i sentito sì scappiamo scappiamo
scappiamo
via aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto questo spigati spati Apri Apri
questa porta Apri questa porta Apri
questa porta Apri APR perché non si oh
Fammi provare a me Fammi provare dai
Apri non si apre spati
spati che cos'era che cos'era che
cos'era l'hai vista anche tu vero Spegni
la pila
ok
[Musica]
[Applauso]
vero
hai visto sì ho visto e mi sono anche
spaventato Spegni questa luce Spegni ci
potrebbe vedere ci riconosce arriva qui
subito è la creatura più grande che io
abbia mai visto e Cor ruggito più
potente che abbia mai sentito finora non
ne abbiamo mai affrontato una così
grossa no non possiamo direttamente
scappare chiunque scapperebbe davanti a
una creatura così grande e mostruosa Ma
che dici Non possiamo scappare c'è
fiamma da sola la creatura potrebbe
prenderla e se ince fosse fiamma La
creatura Come ti ho già detto è vero ma
non possiamo esserne sicuri che cosa
facciamo rischiamo che la creatura si
sbrani fiamma perché abbiamo il sospetto
che sia lei no Effettivamente no hai rag
se poi non fosse lei
anzi non vedo più la creatura potrebbe
essere entrata dentro casa dentro casa
c'è fiamma FMA Oh no andiamo andiamo a
salvarla for dobiamo andare salarla
presto Ecco Questa è l'altra entrata è
meglio entrare da qua sì e speriamo che
fiamma abbia lasciato le porte aperte
altrimenti come facciamo ad entrare
andiamo a controllare
Sì Piano vai piano potrebbe essere qua
Sì hai ragione Io ho aperto questa
adesso la prossima Aprila tu è meglio
spegnere le pile no ma così non vediamo
niente solamo acco solo una Sì sì sì vai
prima tu Ma no io ho aperto la prima
porta tu vai ad aprire la
seconda dobbiamo stare attenti V
[Musica]
io questo salotto è un po' desolato Sì è
vero Beh ci sono altri dubbi che mi Sor
che dubbi perché fiamma abita in questa
casa gigante è vuota ed è anche sola è
un po'
strano lo sapevo Era la creatura non ne
siamo ancora sicuri al 100%
quindi ho visto qualcosa là dietro
dietro la porta o dietro la scatola
dietro la porta adesso stamo il piano di
sopra vai vai
corri presto presto nasconditi
nasconditi ci
nascondiamo
Soto Secondo te siamo nascosti bene qui
No non credo proprio i lupi mannari poi
hanno un olfatto
incredibile Per fortuna che questa
mattina mi sono lavato
e che c'è da ridere senò sai come mi
sente
subito
[Musica]
Ascolta Mi è venuta un'idea lui ci
troverà qui e quando ci troverà punti
mogli subito le torc in faccia e
proviamo ad accecarlo una volta che lo
accheria Sei sicuro che sia una buona
idea Eh no però dobbiamo provarci
Ok tieniti
[Musica]
pronta
scappa via via scappa scappa abbagliano
abbagliano vieni qua
Ara Chiudi chiudi chiudi a chiave presto
passami conella sedia passami conella
sedia non so quanto riuscirà a mantenere
questa
porta e adesso che cosa facciamo
aspettiamo che se ne
vada
Eh sento dei passi che si
allontanano è andato via ho sentito una
porta Sì forse vuole provare a
raggiungerci dalla
finestra chiudiamo la
finestra è già
chiusa ora l'unica cosa da fare e
aspettare che torni la mattina se questa
è una notte di luna piena Sì lui tornerà
normale domani mattina quindi non ci
resta che aspettare non possiamo fare
altro Altrimenti verremo sbranati Ok
quindi dobbiamo solo aspettare vero non
possiamo fare altro adesso
[Musica]
ok
Vitale Sveglia sveglia Sì sì Ho male P
non ci vado a scuola cosa non ci vado a
scuola Vitale c'ho male alla pancia ho
capito Devo svegliarlo alla vecchia
maniera la colazione
pronta Dov'è la colazione Ah ecco
funzionato Ti ricordi che siamo in
questa casa e stiamo scappando da una
creatura gigante un Lom manaro
gigantesco hai detto colazione non
pensare a colazione adesso la creatura
potrebbe ancora essere qua pensi che sia
ancora qua la creatura Non lo so perché
se c'è una cosa che so sui lupi mannari
è che durante la luna piena si
trasformano ma poi la mattina tornano
normali quindi potrebbe essere tornato
normale Eh magari magari è andato via
Allora no possiamo andare a fare
colazione adesso ma non pensare alla
colazione adesso dobbiamo assicurarci
che sia andato via davvero che sia
tornato normale Ehi ma aspetta un
momento e fiamma per tutte le creature
fiamma Dobbiamo controllare come sta Sì
è vero
andiamo sembra non
esserci meglio rimanere prudenti Ok ma
tanto sei il lupo mannareo il giorno
sarà andato via No non è detto
perché vabbè te lo dico dopo me lo dici
dopo cosa c'è una possib
che possibilità te lo spiego dopo Adesso
dobbiamo andare a vedere come sta fiamma
Ok va bene ma poi dopo me lo spieghi Sì
sì Ma fai silenzio Ah ok Me lo spieghi
dopo
allora Eccola Questa è la porta della
camera di fiamma vediamo prima se
sentiamo qualche
rumore mi sembra il momento di fare
scherzi Scusa volevo vedere sei attenta
ai rumori dai R rion SC lo bandaro
potrebbe sbranarti in un boccone Anche
tu però ok prima a te perché sei più
consistente no anche tu potresti
sbranare a me Ok
ok non mi sembra che si senta niente non
sento niente neanch'io via libera allora
piano
piano che cosa è successo
qui sembra che sia esplosa una bomba
fiamma fiamma Oh guarda la finestra è
aperta Magari il lupo mannaro ha preso
fiamma ed è uscito fuori dalla finestra
Ah beh in effetti potrebbe essere
passato di qua visto il caos che c'è qua
dentro cerchiamo qualche indizio
sì Che strano Non mi sembrano vestiti di
fiamma questi
vedi non sembrano vestiti da donna pu
che fiamma è un po' strana quindi
potrebbero benissimo essere i suoi
vestiti Chissà se poi fiamma l' ha
preparati per davvero quei biscotti Beh
me li ha promessi son quasi pronti quasi
pronti quasi pronti però poi dopo non me
li ha fatti mica mangiare eh ma è
possibile che pensi sempre ai biscotti
Dobbiamo trovare una creatura enorme
Lupo andaro più grande che io abbia mai
visto finora alla fine potrebbe anche
essere fiamma La creatura è strano che
sia sparita cioè è troppo una
coincidenza fiamma è sparita è apparsa
la creatura di nuovo è sparita
ma scappiamo scappiamo l' chiusa chiame
l'ho chiusa chi
scappiamo ciè mancato poco E ora che
facciamo dobbiamo nasconderci da qualche
parte presto
Dai prestol
vieni qui nascondi qui ma qui ci
vede Non mi sembra proprio un buon
nascondiglio questo eh non è proprio il
massimo ma non avevo altra idea Aspetta
che mi abbasso ancora un
po' Si vede che siamo nascosti
Sì speriamo solo di averlo chiuso bene a
chiave Che cosa avevi chiuso la finestra
No non avevo chiuso la finestra perché
dovevo chiuderla perché sarà uscita
dalla finestra ci starà cercando Oh no
non ci avevo pensato Ma scusami ma tu
non mi avevi detto che i lupi mannari si
trasformano solo di notte e con la luna
piena oggi è tipo giorno e di giorno non
dovrebbe essere trasformato no E infatti
è come temevo un'antica leggenda narra
che esistono dei lupi mannari che sono
in grado di trasform formarsi a comando
quando vogliono indipendentemente dalla
luna piena o dal buio dal sole dal
giorno dalla luce Credo che questa sia
una di quelle razze di lupi mannari Ma
chi te l'ha raccontata questa leggenda
Beh è una leggenda che mi ha raccontato
Alex il lupo Ti ricordi l'X lui è un
esperto di mostri un mostralo mi aveva
raccontato di questo lupo mannaro ma
pensavo che non esistessero i lupi
mannare così ma evidentemente esistono e
sono una razza più forte Oh no E adesso
cosa facciamo Cosa possiamo fare Hai
qualche idea eh Qualche idea Lo sai che
io ho delle idee solo quando si tratta
di C di
cibo Aspetta forse mi è venuta un'idea
Non mi dire che stai solo pensando a
mangiare come sempre cioè non solo
pensando a mangiare come sempre Però
potrebbe esserci qualcosa di buono che
ne esce fuori eh tu aspettami qua non ti
preoccupare Ci penso io Copriti bene qui
con Il nascondiglio Ok so quello che
faccio o almeno ci credo stai attento Sì
va
bene speriamo che abbia avuto davvero
una buona idea e non una delle sue
trovate per riuscire a mangiare di
più se non ricordo male erano proprio
qui sì non mi sbagliamo Eccoli i
biscotti m m sono ancora
buoni
m
oh no oh
no no sono spacciato adesso sono
spacciato Vitale stai bene stai Stai
bene che cosa è successo Sto bene sto
bene mi hai salvato grazie eh
praticamente Questo vassoio d'argento e
mi ha aiutato contro contro il lupo
mannaro aspetta spiegami cosa ci facevi
in questa stanza con questo vassoio mi
ero accorto che c'era questo vassoio coi
biscotti sopra e avevo notato che era un
vassoio d'argento Io ho pensato Magari è
un vassoio d'argento che serve come arma
per contro i lupi Mann non ci credo sei
stato salvato grazie ai biscotti Grazie
alla tua pancia come sempre ma ora non
perdiamo
[Musica]
tempo Dov'è il lupo mannaro Eh non lo so
era lì un attimo fa Sì pensavo che tu
l'avessi sconfitto l'ho
volatilizzato non credo che sia
scomparso potrebbe essere scappato no
peccato abbiamo perso l'occasione di
catturare una creatura così rara e
pericolosa e poi c'è sempre il problema
che si ripresenti dici che torno fiamma
fiamma Sì ma quindi sei
viva Mi sono persa qualche cosa Eh stai
bene m sai è che abbiamo avuto una
nottata un po' particolare non sei un
fantasma vero
no che è successo Ragazzi ma avete una
cera
bruttissima che è successo Beh abbiamo
affrontato la creatura stanotte il lupo
mannaro esatto Ed è stato paurosissimo
ma ho una domanda per te Tu dov'eri
tutto quel tempo ma ma come dov'ero E dm
dormivo Anita dormivo ma come dormivi
Noi siamo entrati in stanza tua e non
c'eri Infatti non c'era nessuno sul
letto allora Ma Ma certo È ovvio c'è una
spiegazione c'è sempre una spiegazione a
tutto Ah sì E sentiamo quale sarebbe
questa spiegazione e sapete io ho
difficoltà nell' addormentarmi e ho
anche il sonno molto leggero per cui ho
l'abitudine di dormire sotto il letto a
letto Certo con la mascherina negli
occhi tappi nelle orecchie non mi sono
accorta di nulla anzi è stata una notata
così serena per me in effetti non
abbiamo controllato sotto al letto
Potrebbe essere vero Certo È verissimo è
verissimo ma ma voi Voi come state voi
Beh noi dai abbastanza bene ci siamo
salvati per un pelo m Abbiamo affrontato
la creatura Come la creatura Sì è stato
rischioso ma almeno l'abbiamo affrontata
Il problema è che è scappata scappata
lontano Eh sì sì è scappata lontano è
scappata lontano quindi caso risolto È
stato un piacere piacerissimo Grazie
arrivederci Noi andiamo a fare colazione
Io prendo due crossan e li facciamo con
la crema il caffè il cappuccino il
cornetto il succo di frutta e a presto
ci vediamo presto Tanti saluti grazie
grazie stai dicendo la colazione
dobbiamo fare la colazione non è un caso
risolto abbiamo risolto il caso come non
è risolto non è risolto la creatura è
scappata sarebbe risolto se avessimo
affrontato la creatura e l'avessimo
sconfitta ma è scappata potrebbe
ripresentarsi abbiamo fallito questo
caso mi dispiace no no
Anita quale fallito ma ma voi mi avete
salvato mi avete salvato E non
basteranno mille ringraziamenti Sì
grazie grazie sarò sempre in debito con
voi sempre e poi sapete avete salvato
anche le mie scoperte A tal proposito
abbiamo trovato una cosa molto strana
sotterrata in giardino e beh sembrava
tipo una specie di
uovo l'uovo di Dragon Rana ma ma io l'ho
sotterrato perché solo il buio può
schiudersi E l'avete l'avete ris
soterrado
eh Sì ma che cos'è questo drago rana
esattamente e dunque il drago rana
esattamente non posso spiegare ora Che
cos'è però è importantissimo che si
schiuda sotto terra perché potrebbe
trasformarsi ma non so neanche io In che
cosa Eh sì sì l'abbiamo sotterrato
l'abbiamo sotterrato ma A tal proposito
che facciamo colazione per caso visto
che il caso è chiuso tutto quanto uovo
sotterrato andiamo a mangiare dai Caso
chiuso so non abbiamo risolto un bel
niente La creatura è scappata l'avremmo
dovuta catturare l'avremmo dovuta
eliminare non è risolto proprio per
niente il caso ci siamo fatti scappare
La creatura c'è un lato positivo in
tutta questa faccenda Mi avete salvata e
non basteranno mille
ringraziamenti avete salvato anche le
mie scoperte sarò sempre Inde debito con
voi Anzi devo terminare di preparare le
mie valigie e riprendere il viaggio ma
come il viaggio adesso che si parlava di
colazione e non ci ha offerto Neanche un
cioccolatino già se ne va via e va via
in vacanza e la colazione il
cioccolatino ma soprattutto i
biscotti Ma figuriamoci Ma quale vacanza
chi ce l'ha il tempo di andare in
vacanza con tutte le formule che bisogna
ancora scoprire sto andando a cercare
l'ultimo ingrediente per la mia nuova
ricetta un ingrediente molto molto
speciale Ah ho capito Si tratta di
quella ricerca importantissima di cui ci
parlavi ieri ma di cui ancora non ci
puoi svelare niente Beh comunque ti
auguro di trovare l'ingrediente che
cerchi
e grazie tra virgolette per averci
ospitato in questa casa gigante per noi
ora è il momento di andare dobbiamo
tornare dal nostro Merlino e Circe e vi
piace la mia gigantesca casa che
coincidenza Stavo proprio pensando di
farvi una proposta perché non restate
qua restare qua ma in tendi tipo a
viverci Ma certo andate a prendere i
vostri amici Mago Merlino E maga Circe e
venite a stare qui e potreste prendervi
cura di questa casa e forse controllare
un po' Nel caso dovessero ritornare
altre creature Ma no Merlino e Circe
sono i nostri amici pelosetti Merlino è
il nostro cagnolone e circhetta invece è
la nostra gattina Aspetta un momento
però hai detto altre creature Cosa
intendi dire eh
mi sono espressa male Volevo dire che
potreste restare qua in questa casa Sono
sicura che trovereste molto divertente
trascorrere il tempo qui Aspetta sto
pensando una cosa Questo potrebbe essere
finalmente l'occasione per realizzare il
mio sogno quale sogno il mio sogno il
mio sogno Ecco devi sapere il mio sogno
è aprire un'agenzia
investigativa investigare Ma io sono
bravissimo ad investigare potrei
investigare ad esempio su tipo se c'è un
biscotto e poi all'improvviso scompare
la crema io posso investigare su come ha
fatto quella crema a scomparire anche se
nella maggior parte dei casi quella
crema non intendo questo intendo
un'agenzia investigativa in cui potremo
indagare su tutti i fenomeni paranormali
noi potremmo essere gli investigatori
poi magari potremmo creare un team di
persone che ci aiutano non lo so uno
scienziato un inventore un astrologo una
strega un cuoco è un'idea
strepitosa con tutto lo spazio che avete
a disposizione qua e sarà semplicissimo
creare la vostra agenzia Ma sì come
metodo di pagamento potremmo ad esempio
accettare torte cannoncini cannoncini la
crema ma anche supplì parmigian Allora
fiamma Noi accettiamo la tua proposta e
non ti preoccupare per la casa Ce ne
prenderemo cura sicuramente Anzi sono
così emozionato finalmente apriremo la
nostra agenzia investigativa E allora io
vi saluto ragazzi il mio treno sta per
partire ed è meglio che mi sbrighi ogni
tanto tornerò a trovarvi e statemi bene
cari arrivederci
arrivederci poi potremmo anche
fare poi anche i su con con anche Vitale
Sì Fiamma sta andando via che cosa stai
facendo Eh Stavo elencando tutti i
metodi di pagamento di cibo che possiamo
che possiamo accettare ma no non pensare
metodo di pagamento adesso salutiamo
fiamma presto ok andiamo a salutarla non
me nero accorto fiamma aspetta Ciao
fiamma volevamo augurarti un buon
viaggio e buona fortuna per le tue
scoperte buon viaggio Ciao grazie ancora
grazie a voi ragazzi tornerò prestissimo
[Musica]
Arrivederci Ehi vi ricordo di ordinare
subito la città stregata agli
investigatori del mistero cliccate nel
link in descrizione Per ordinarlo
subito Beh ora non ci manca che una sola
cosa il nome dell'agenzia investigativa
che noi potremmo dare alla nostra
agenzia investigativa di misteri e cose
soprannaturali scrivetecelo nei commenti
Non vedo l'ora vivremo un sacco di
avventure assieme Mi raccomando lasciate
un mi piace iscrivetevi e attivate la
campanella e teniamoci pronti per i
nuovi casi da risolvere
[Musica]
insieme
n